this is a production of Cornell
University
good morning or good afternoon or good
night wherever you are it's a real
pleasure to be here and I would like to
thank the synapses durin group for this
really excellent organization and also
Cordova for sponsoring with fantastic
international series of symposia when I
was asked to give a title I thought this
was several months ago when I said well
it all amounts to eat more beans little
did I know that actually people do eat
more beans apparently at least they buy
more beans in this time but it is in
order to eat more beans we have to
produce more beans and so there is a
genetic component to it and what I would
like to illustrate today is how the
knowledge of the phylogeny but also of
the differential or environmental
origins of common bean effect
domestication and affect agronomic
traits that we can use in breeding so I
would like to thank the members of my
group
I picked a picture of last year today
this group is somewhat he shows up as
those squares on a zoom screen but they
are hanging in there and so I'm very
grateful for that I also would like to
thank sources of funding which have been
USDA nifA
and various sources in the industry so
in line with the the general theme of
the symposium bringing back biodiversity
I will
discuss first give you an overall
introduction of what we know at this
stage of common being homogeny or
genealogy and then discuss three
specific topics a better understanding
of the genetic diversity and climatic
distribution of the wild progenitor of
common being and that is the work of
Andrea
ariani who was a postdoc in my lab and
is now working in Kent with Bayer and
the second topic will be the based on
that first topic is can we use the wild
progenitor to derive drought tolerance
and that is the work of Korea Bernie who
was a former student and postdoc from
Mexico and has just returned to his
country and the third topic is to look
at part in the hissings as a
domestication trade but also as it
results is a aridity tolerance trait and
that is the work of Travis Parker and
Travis is very polyvalent you seen my
background here series of varieties of
heirloom varieties that he is releasing
now that have virus resistance and
that's part of his thesis as well so
what do we know about the phylogeny of
se almost all garrison our view is being
kind of inference by the idea of gene
pool so similarities between different
populations or lines initially which we
we knew that the distribution of wild
common being here in the Americas is
extremely large the gene is itself
originated in what is now called Mexico
and that's why you find most of the
species but we also see that some
species have expanded their range in to
South America
also North America as well as some of
the islands that surround the Americas
and one of the questions is how did this
come about when did this come about and
what is the effect on the overall
genetic diversity of this is wild taxon
actually so early on we had determined
that there was a most of the diversity
was actually assessed in incoming me
through their domestication the
domesticated varieties but outside of
the central rule of origin there was
very little study about the diversity of
land races for example and also
especially on the in wild potential my
progenitor so first result was that the
domesticated gene pool results actually
from two separate domestication x' one
of them in the southern Andes and the
other one in Mexico a second important
result was that the land races both in
the Mesoamerican gene pool and the
Anglin gene pool could be subdivided
into eco Geographic races so they had a
specific geography also ecology and
certainly also morphology as well as
some economic traits like disease
resistances and so on and so in the
Mesoamerican gene pool you had three
first three now four races and I draw
your attention on top more about that
later on about a distinction between
race Jalisco which is a Highland race
and and raised Durango which is also a
hard race but there is a distinction in
terms of the amount of aridity that they
are subject to and raised the Rango is
from northern Mexico and so is subject
to much more arid climate versus the
race Mesoamerica here which is typically
a low
and more humid race and then race
what Amala has recently been added and I
suspect that it's kind of a Geographic
variant of this race Jalisco from
central Mexico in the Andean gene pool
among the land races you see three races
the most common one the one that we know
the best is nueva Granada
that has many of the Bush determinate
beings but you also have a race Chile
which is not well known and then race
Peru which comes from the central part
of the Andes in turn these some of these
races have been dispersed outside their
centers of domestication especially in
racemate America embraced Durango race
Calais going what Amana have been left
behind the same thing here is waste my
bagon inada and maybe to a certain
extent race Chile have been disseminated
to the rest of the world but race Peru
has been left behind so these races that
have been left behind it's because of
their photo period sensitivity and
interactions with temperature and so
many times when you see a gene Watson
alysus it's based on materials here
domesticated varieties outside the
centers of origin and there are
significant misses in these G was panels
as well as in the as in the jump azzam
collections for example the USDA gem
class collection as a deficiency in
these race Peru raised Jalisco and so on
a third finding was that if you look
here at the map again you see the red
group that is amazing group the blue
group is the southern engine group and
then you have this yellow group which is
initially was a gap an artificial gap in
the collection but turns out to have
fairly unique character
including the existence of ancestral
sequences of the major seed protein so
that was added just at the late 80s late
early 90s although common being is
reputed to be a mostly selfing specious
we see evidence that there is crossing
between wild and domesticated types such
that the diversity of the wild type is
actually diminished because of gene flow
from the domesticated types into the
wild populations that are sympatric with
these domesticated population in in
Mexico and also receive the same
phenomena in the Andes and either a
legacy or more recently breeders have
attempted or intend actually integrates
the tool a major gene pools that have
been domesticated
inbreeding for example it's to introduce
mostly Mesoamerican alleles for disease
resistance into the Andes overall you
see a much more reduced genetic
diversity in the engine gene pool
compared to the Mesoamerican gene pool
now the Angela gene pool although it has
less diversity
it has qualitatively it has different
alleles of different genes that have
been selected so they form a valuable
component of a gene mag and so I look at
three topics in this genealogy the first
one is to better understand what the
relationship is between these world gene
pools in Mesoamerica in the Andes as
well as here this group of Ecuador in
northern Peru
I will then also look at how maybe we
can read Emes the gate wild beings by
incorporating genes for drought
tolerance into the domesticated gene
pool and in the third place I'll look at
the genetics of shadowing part
chattering which appears to be a
characteristic of this raised durango so
far so the reason i think the motivation
to to look at these wild beings is to
try to understand this wide distribution
from northern Mexico to Northwest
Argentina and this is a more or less
continuous distribution of ten thousand
kilometers but there are some gaps which
we now know are real gaps are not just
gaps in the collection and they
correspond to lower lying areas which
are hot and humid
so while beans prefer these kind of
moderate temperatures moderate rainfall
but the question is how did we get to
such a distribution and when did this
happen
so you see here this photo is a
population photo taken in December at
the end of the cycle all great battles
are shrubs unrelated to wild beans and
you see the the massive pod load here of
his wild beans at the end of their cycle
I've taken here photos all along this
distribution of wild beans and it's an
environment that is heavily impacted by
humans which is an argument for ex situ
conservation at least in part well what
it also show the map here is that there
is differentiation of these alternations
all along the distribution you have
primarily here a group in Mexico
but then also a group that represents a
range expansion into Central America and
Colombia and then you have these two and
young groups from Ecuador and on in Peru
here and then from the southern Andes
okay so the reason we knew that there
was geographic differentiation so the
idea now is to conduct genotyping by
sequencing on a collection of about
250-300
of wild populations that are
representative of the entire
distribution and what undernea did was
an in silico analysis based on the
genome reference sequence with different
enzymes and to see identified enzyme
that we really have a broad distribution
across the genome and so what you see on
the right here is a comparison of this
CDIA to enzyme he identified compared to
with the the more traditionally used a
PE k1 and you see that a large number of
total sites this is the recognition
sequence of this site is only for bases
and it's not methylation sensitive the
genome of means is much smaller than for
example maize it's about 600 million so
we could afford to have to use a an
enzyme that was had more recognition
sites and you see also that the effect
of using see BIA to is that you tagged a
larger number of gene models in the bean
genome and it's thought that the
approximately 97% of the gene models
were tagged compared to about 60% for a
PE k1
so did this way of approaching did it
first confirm what we knew already or
and it turns out that is that that is
the case you see again the distribution
here of wild means there is a large
group here which represents the original
area of distribution and then a
dissemination a to dissemination among
distant dissemination events the yellow
one here and then the blue one but which
have much less diversity now this
configuration of the snip diversity in
the wild means matches that of the the
snip configuration in domesticated types
and you see here the Mex the
Mesoamerican domesticated gene pool and
on the right side this very tight
cluster of Andean domesticates and
consistent with the reduction in
diversity you see following this
dispersal from is America into the Andes
and then along the second axis you see a
separation of the highland races
especially the raised Durango and here
the lowland race race Mesoamerica now
the the reason I think for the the
reduction in diversity you see here in
the Andean group it's several fold first
one is that we see a very strong
correlation between the latitude and the
principal component scores and this
correlation breaks down around fifteen
degree northern latitude which
corresponds to this line here
and so from this this latitude all down
you have a very narrow distribution
which accounts for art of this reduction
in diversity the second reason is that
probably these
termination events are fairly rare and
there was a modeling studies done
separately by European scientists a few
years ago documenting that if you see a
rare a rare event of long-distance
dispersal you tend to generate what they
called an embolism effect where one or a
limited number of haplotypes take over
the distribution at a distance and you
see here the number of generations and
then the the starting point of the
dispersal event is at the bottom and you
see as with time you go and you see this
embolism effect of reducing genetic
diversity the other argument is that
really the the habitat that is suitable
for these wild beads is extremely narrow
if you look at the Andes for example in
Ecuador we found these wild beans the
triangles here only in one particular
vegetation type of type of forest on the
western side of the Andes here in
Ecuador and and Colombia and Peru as
well actually further to the south in a
different collection we found the wild
beings at the transition between two
vegetation type it's still a very narrow
habitat which probably helped or also
led to this embolism effect we see now
you can look at the diversity here and
that's where it's this genomic approach
became useful in that we see whether we
look at gene events or non-genic
variants it's the same you have the tree
here has a root in the group from
Ecuador and northern Peru
and the distinction between Andean and
Mesoamerican types only comes afterwards
after this first migration to Ecuador
you have a second migration to to the
southern Andes but it comes after when
the first separation is really this
small group in Ecuador in northern Peru
as I told you this small group has some
ancestral sequences and which are not
found even though they are ancestral in
the area of origin in Mesoamerica so we
have somewhat of a paradox where
ancestral sequences have become extinct
in the area of origin but survived till
today in a derived derived area when did
these events happen you can date them
and there are several groups that have
dated them and they come with more or
less consistent results so the first
long-term dispersal was around 500,000
years ago and the second dispersal was
it took place about a hundred thousand
years ago and then this was followed by
two domestication x' one in the southern
Andes and when in Mesoamerica about five
to ten thousand years ago so
that we have these long distant
dispersal we have we know approximately
when they happen how did they happen and
what were the vectors really that caused
that I love this dispersal to take place
and you see here the potential is
migratory birds you have to account for
a vector that is able to bridge these
large depression area like the Isthmus
of Panama the Isthmus of Tehuantepec he
also the Chaco region in Colombia and
and one observation is that we did in
Ecuador was that they we saw bird damage
actually the birds tend to want to eat
the seeds they nibble at the tip towards
the tip of the pod the pod opens and
presumably they then eat the seed and I
remind you that these are wild seeds and
they are much smaller about 1/10 smaller
than the smallest domesticated seeds and
the local name for wild beans is
actually free on the Paloma or dove or
pigeon being actually that raises the
question are there pigeons that have
such a distribution that have migration
and we see several examples of this here
and so it suggests that that the this
long long distance dispersal may have
taken place who birds but it raises a
series of questions also and I won't get
into that
okay so we can now add some more details
to this phylogeny that the yellow here
gene pool of Ecuador in northern Peru
has since been renamed as a separate
species based on the ecology its age and
also the metabolomic results
by Mexican scientists which show that
this wild type is more closely related
to Phase II almost coxinhas than to face
a loss or Gerrits and also we can add
the dates for this separation now as I
said these are two domestication in
Mesoamerica and and the Andes
they are well-documented and it seemed
to me that there is an incipient
speciation because you have in ten or
fifteen percent of the cross as you see
reproductive isolation as if one in
viability or if one stability okay one
of the questions then is among these two
major group the two gene pools of wild
beings can we identify sources of
drought tolerance and the idea was that
well wild beans have been subjected to
these various climatic cycles and they
have survived it
so not only for at least five hundred
thousand years as it turns out if you
look at the distribution of climatic
conditions among among these wild beings
and again you see here the distribution
of wild beans in the Americas we see
four groups or three groups actually one
of them is present at the extremes of
the distribution and is characterized by
a long dry season of at least six months
towards the equator however you have
also wild means and there that the
season is much shorter but it's still
there and the thinking is that these
even short seasons are necessary for
pouch to shatter okay and hence the the
third topic I will be addressing is that
pod shattering but the question is so
how hypotheses are these beans from the
especially the dry areas are they good
sources of variant of variation for
drought tolerance
so this is the work of convey Bernie as
I told you he's a former graduate
student very productive also postdoc and
he is now returned to Yucatan his native
Yucatan in Mexico so again this is the
study that under the eye beyond yet
conduct that you see there is a
structure analysis where the accessions
are listed here according to their
latitude and so you see three
Mesoamerican groups orange the yellow
and the blue one here you see this
intermediate group from Ecuador and
northern Peru and you have the southern
Andes group if we look compare these
their data of origin with climatic data
for these locations what we see is that
the driest areas are indeed at the
extremities you see wild mw1 group here
in northern Mexico the Andean wild group
in Argentina primarily they are the
driest I'm sorry on the other hand you
look at the temperature the hottest is
here around the equator but combined
with the driest group here it seems like
a candidate for candidate region for
drought tolerance ought to be in
northern Mexico so
Quora he was faced with a difficulty
however that it's very difficult to
assess or to evaluate wild populations
on their own and there's a number of
reasons for that you see first of all
the growth habits in the natural
environment so these are climbing Viney
types difficult to to manage
they also shatter so it's difficult to
measure yield they are photo period
sensitive and also they have their
differences in their seeds the number of
seeds and the size of the seeds so a way
around this is not easy but what he did
was then to do a test cross or nested
populations where he took three wild
populations along a gradient of
precipitation and so you have here it in
a sense a humid control from Guatemala
with rainfall of two thousand
millimeters you have an intermediate
case here about eight hundred
millimeters and then in population in
the north of Mexico about five hundred
millimeters these three populations were
crossed to the same domesticated lion as
a tester and the domesticated line had
been previously also bred for drought
tolerance so the idea was to see can we
obtain even higher drought tolerance in
the domesticated gene pool there weren't
three environments in 2014 and 2015
well watered and then in 2012 15 we
compared their well watered versus the
terminal drought so this is what the
kind of one of the bean fields looked
like and you can see there is a square
here of green plants and these are the
progenies of these crosses with wild
beans they
tend to be later even if we select
against against the late flowering type
that result from photo period
sensitivity so God is selected against
these and you see a clearly bimodal
population indicating that there is a
single major gene and we know that this
is the PPD gene which also has recently
been identified by Jim Weller in
Australia and Martha's entire in Spain
this is what the seeds look like you
have c5 cross - one of the wild
populations you have an f1 here it's one
back cross and then four generations of
selfing and that's the diversity you see
here so the results are that this was
the average yield of c5 the domesticated
parent that is really the control among
the the rills you could you saw a
variation what was hopeful even though
the mean was below the domesticated type
you had some bills that were of above
need the yield of the domesticated
parents the factors population
environment and population by
environment all significance the
population means and I've color-coded
them from the red is the driest one from
the North dry population here from the
central area and then the wet population
from Guatemala here is in green and you
see that the highest actually the two
highest near the populations are really
from the drier area and not from the wet
area
the were also clear differences between
the three environments and 2014 was a
bad year lots of insects and so on but
situation got better in our 2015 now
this graph shows the three per the three
environment three populations in the
three environments you have a
well-watered in 2014 one one in 2015 and
a terminal drought you see here the
yield of c5 the domesticated control and
on the averages are of these three
descendant populations are not higher
than c5 per se but what was hopeful was
that there were individual mines that
were way above the domesticated parent
okay so that was hopeful we conducted a
population with genotype with a snip low
density and snip and you see a number of
qtls appearing they tend to be grouped
and some of them are really grouped at
the ends of chromosomes which is
consistent what do we know about gene
distribution in general so the number of
qtls there were nine in one of the two
well water treatments in under drought
there were five qtls for yield and the
mean across the three treatments were
all some 5qt outs the effect of these
Beauty else was as predicted small from
one to five percent the additive effect
and that is the more interesting aspect
is that the largest positive effect came
from this population in the intermediate
population in the well water condition
in 2015 the smallest of them this is a
negative effect came from the population
from Guatemala which originated in a
rainy type of
[Music]
environment in well-watered conditions
so the overall it looks like the green
the the the well watered a population
the the population from the rainy area
in Guatemala did not have a positive
effect okay up I'm sorry when we
calculated the averages of these
additive effects however in the well
watered condition the the three
population didn't really contribute to
yield overall although the effect was
fairly small if you compare to the yield
of c-5 the domesticated to her parent it
was a slightly negative
however when we look at the effects on
the drought the
[Music]
curations from the dry area had a strong
positive effect on strong additive
effect and again the population from
Guatemala from the moist area did not
really contribute to yield so our
reasoning is the here our conclusion
temperature so far is that these
populations from the drier areas are
extremely valuable for drought tolerance
they don't affect the well watered
conditions but they help the
domesticated types under drought
conditions an additional evidence for
that is that you can identify and these
are five lines that on the average over
the three environments both well watered
and dry environments yield significantly
more than the domesticated control and
that varies most of the cases in a
favorable environment whether it's well
watered or drought stressed they were
above the domesticated control okay so
it was a positive there was a separate
experiment I don't have time to talk
about it with these lines these wild
populations were grown in a greenhouse
experiment and it turns out that the
wild populations from drier areas have
deeper relatively deeper routing system
and are also able to reshape their
routing system under drought stress more
efficiently for the same amount of
biomass also wild beans have a tendency
of even in the presence of drought of
continuing their growth whereas
domesticated type stop their growth for
as long as need the drought conditions
persist so it wasn't in the sense there
is a consistent body of data that if
you're looking at wild needs for drought
tolerance clearly you have
you have the choice of wild populations
and we can use GIS to identify such a
population the choice of the testing
environment you definitely have to use
drought that seems obvious but even in
the well watered conditions the yield
overall will not be affected the choice
of trades I've mentioned to these wild
beans have deeper roots and continued
their growth and the choice of the
breeding method we used one back Ross
and that was a choice a deliberate
choice because we wanted to introduce as
much as possible diversity from the wild
types okay and so what is left to do is
to integrate these what these progeny
lines the the best progeny lines into a
regular breeding program how am i doing
on time here ah
ok thanks so I just a the last item in
each related to this you'll see the
drought tolerance is that hard in the
hissings is a domestication trait
because that is widely recognized now
the fact is that part the essence has
survived in the domesticated gene pool
this is the work of Travis Parker who is
also the author of the these new newly
released varieties and as part of his
thesis he also looked at the in the
essence genetics
so you see here again a population of
wild beans you see the plants here they
carry down parts they don't immediately
release these seeds even though they are
really their reach maturity and so
that's why you need this period of dry
dry period to allow the pants to to free
up their seed through the essence when
you have the histones you have this
characteristic kind of compost feature
here where the two valves of the pants
separate and also twist and the twisting
Archer conveys a a slingshot movement to
the to the seed which spread the seeds
around the plant and you see this here
this is pods of wild beans has sharply
twisted valves this is a dried bean when
there is still some twisting meant much
less and then this is a green bean ah
snap bean at the right here when the pod
does not open at all there are different
genetic systems for the green bean and
the dry being domesticated times the
system of the green bean is epistatic on
to the dry bean pod the decent system I
won't talk about that in this talk but I
won't talk about the the genetics of
this upon indications and you see here
two varieties of the breeding program
you see this variety was developed by
Steve temple because the this variety
showed heavy and he are chattering and
it is a surprises why is this trait that
is deleterious still survive in the
domesticated term plans so you see that
also in the different market classes
here and especially prone to shattering
are the cranberries somewhat they're
also the kidneys in the engine gene
and then in the mesoamerican gene pool
you have the small blacks and the Navy's
okay so Travis used are three methods
one is the evaluation in the field
shattering no shattering and simple then
an oven method where you put the temper
the power to sample the pods at 65
degrees for a week you let them
equilibrate after that and you counted
the number of pods that shattered and
then a force method that in imposes a
force and measure the force that is
needed to shatter the part
so the result of that is that if you do
a QTL analysis in a population it is
amazing American population the three
methods actually give you the same
result with a major QTL on chromosome 3
what is different however is that the
methods the more precise the method the
higher the LOD score and the fraction of
of the phenotype phenotypic variation
represented okay and so you have some
lots covers of 50 actually I think
wouldn't we all like to have a lot score
of 50 so then the the peak here actually
includes a homologue of the PTH it's
partly hastens that had been identified
in soybean as well and is the there is a
kind of AGID for that and it's called a
diligent gene which helps assemble the
lignin polymer from each individual
monomers okay Travis then also looked at
G was type of analysis with two panels
that had been developed in beans went
for the Mesoamerican domestication and
the other for the Andean undomesticated
gene he confirmed that location on
chromosome 3 and there was also one
potentially here on chromosome 8
in the andean group there is apparently
the same the same peak but it is when
you look at the detail of the data it's
on chromosome 3 also but it's not quite
the same peak so it may be a different a
different gene involved on chromosome 3
and he confirmed what other researchers
had found a separate peak on chromosome
5 so on the face of it actually the two
domestication x' have achieved the same
result reduction in indications but
through sometimes different genes one of
the things that you can do is do a
principal component analysis of these
panels and the in the Mesoamerican panel
the the principal component the first
bits of a component separates raised
Durango which is highlight and dry and
raise Mesoamerica which is lowland and
more humid what you see is that the
group that is classified as raised
Durango in its majority has the mutation
that is correlated with the part
resistance to shattering and so you see
very low levels of shattering in this
range to learn more this is a race that
is represented in the US with the pintos
the great northerns for example on the
other hand in basements of america you
have a much greater variation in the
amount of the hisses there is a mutation
among a few of the lines and this is the
the the QTL we had identified on
chromosome 8 so different lineages have
different reaction to part the hisses
and different mutations leading to cutie
else of controlling part in the essence
this is a fantastic table but it's
originally you can't read this but in it
shows
the the the the jeans or qtls that have
been identified related to pod in the
hastens both in green beans and dry
beans and pretty much a large majority
of the chromosomes are involved in this
so we can answer the question yesterday
at the beginning is to say why is it
that some market classes still have
these dehiscence and I suggest here that
you have multiple genes involved each of
them reduces the essence however when
you cross these lines with separate the
decent genes you restore you complement
actually these genes your f1 will start
shattering but whether or not you'll see
it depends on the environmental
condition under which you condition you
can you conduct your breeding program
under dry areas under wet areas you will
not see the shattering and so you can
perpetuate through these crosses you can
perpetuate the issue of dehiscence and
in California where it's very dry in the
summer we immediately notice when there
is pod the essence
okay so again and also the this having
this filler phylogeny and the adaptation
of the different gene pools and being
able to place the different mutations on
this helps us understand the genetic
variation present in this species
am I out of time so you are gonna have
about ten minutes for questions after
here oh let me quickly so I think
domestication is often seen as the
beginning of Agriculture I considered to
be the apotheosis of hunter-gatherers
it's important to understand planted
crops
and while then domesticated types have
very different the selected regimes in
terms of plant type part the seed
dispersal it's one it is possible to
identify groups of wild means associated
with different environmental conditions
in terms of drought tolerance we need to
define the taxa populations the genes
and the traits that are valid can be
pursued while beings from the driest
areas are very useful in terms of
drought tolerance certain something to
pursue and the comparative approaches
are very useful and I think that here we
have talked about common being but let
me remind you that there are four other
domesticated species there is lima bean
or which also has a double domestication
and then you have runner bean temporary
being and year bean and these show a
different gradation in domestication so
I think that we are going to turn
towards more comparative studies here so
thanks very much for your attention
awesome thank you that was a wonderful
talk and also really highlighting the
importance of crop wild relatives and
some of the diversity that can be found
in them it looks like we already have
one question ready to go with anyone
else has questions please feel free to
either raise your hand through the zoom
function or type in your question via
chat so it looks like Joyce cherry if
you would like to unmute yourself hello
can you hear me yes thank you very much
for the talk I recently started working
with Phase II old school Garris thinking
about the vining habit that's found in
some of the races and I've been curious
now from your talk if there is any
relationship with plant habit
and yield yes there is absolutely a
relationship
Viney types yield about two to three
times more than bush types and so if
you'll allow me and so why you say why
why do people plant bush types but it's
for economic reasons is that they
require the Viney types require more
labor okay now there are conditions
where there is labor available and so if
you go to or one that for example the
London government has policies in place
to stimulate production of beans because
it's an essential source of proteins in
the diet of people of wonder in the
surrounding countries and so in
originally in the country I think
Viney types were about 10% of being
production now they are above 50% and so
this is a conscious move to rely on
these Viney types to increase bean
production by their London government I
did I answer your question yes you did I
have a follow-up is is that because the
vining types produce more leaf biomass
or is it because they were excessively
access light do it do we know why
they're able more yield well the
immediate relationship is the number of
nodes because at every node you have a
leaf but also you have an inflorescence
with flowers and then ponds and so the
number of nodes is much bigger in a
Viney type than in a bush type literally
okay and there are different Viney types
actually there is a whole range in terms
of climbing aggressiveness and so on so
you have to be careful about which
genotype you pick and in in one
for example day it's a monoculture of
beets don't grow corn and beans so they
have to have so they use kind of sticks
as a support and in the breeding process
you have to be careful not to breed for
beans climbing beans that are too
vigorous because they're going to topple
the sticks actually thank you very much
you for the question okay looks like we
have another question from Hannah
Jeffery if you could unmute yourself hi
there I am a Dutton a student of dr.
Karen C he usda-ars dry bean breeding
and genetics program and I'm currently
conducting research on beans as in
relation to their cooking time so I was
just wondering um certain I was just
wondering if you what your opinions were
about fluttering and flooding tolerance
have you seen any of that in your
research are you not looking for that
right now because flooding tolerance is
also an important consideration in
Michigan I believe as we get more just
more rainfall in general than you would
expect in perhaps Mexico for some of
these varieties yeah we have not
addressed and I know it's probably
Michigan also North Dakota North Dakota
especially yes so but in California we
have a hard time disc justifying
research on flooding we are principally
preoccupied with with drought conditions
now I could ask a good answer also where
would we go would wild beans be a good
source of flooding tolerance well maybe
some of these beans from on the opposite
end of the gradient I showed you in
Guatemala where they have 2,000
millimetres of rainfall it might be a
better choice you would make the
opposite calculation naturally okay okay
but I'm not sure I don't have experience
with that right okay it's very nice to
meet you sir thank you for your question
no problem oh by the way was my be 86
brought up by another presenter earlier
that is possible but I've not been able
to follow it was a it was about the
dehiscence is about a yes anyway I just
thought it was interesting okay like we
have another question Taylor would you
like to ask your question thanks for the
great talk dr. Paul my question is very
linked a drive in using the wide roll
relatives as a source of Tolerance and
if so how to deal with that thank you
yeah I think that that's a good question
and you know I I say we have superior
lines but we have yet and they have the
same days to flowering there are
slightly smaller seeds than the
domesticated control so the next step is
to really transfer the grant dollars
into commercial classes and I think that
this is an issue of empowered linkage
drag or linkage disequilibrium will we
be able to recover the seeds with the
colors that we need to fit into a
commercial class these color genes are
distributed also on many many
chromosomes I mean I consider this to be
almost like a fixed part of the genome
we have to achieve we have to get those
and will we have enough recombination
between these set of colored genes for
example the growth habit genes
and the set of cootie ELLs that we
identified as conferring drought
tolerance overall there is less linkage
lag in the in the wild types compared to
domesticated type of it here we are in a
domesticated argument we have used one
back row set for trial or self in
generations so they will not break up
really the the linkages but now I think
that that is one of the major problems
in common being breeding because there
is so much importance on the appearance
of the the the seeds and that these
genes on distributed all over the genome
so I think I think it's a good question
but we don't know at this stage okay I
think it's a problem whether you use
wild beans are domesticated beans as a
source of diversity awesome oh we are
out of time now
but if people have more questions for
Paul he will be having a breakout
session during our next coffee break at
3:45
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu